Seinfeld is undoubtedly one of the
greatest and most important TV comedies
of all time
it's been off the air for nearly 20
years but millions still watch the
reruns every day both in syndication and
online after nine seasons and 180
episodes plenty of onset silliness was
left on the cutting room floor here are
some of the funniest bloopers from the
set of sign town not camera worthy
nothing ever seems to go right for
unlucky loser George Costanza it would
seem that some of that bad luck rubbed
off on actor Jason Alexander at least in
this blooper the camera is supposed to
follow him off screen but it doesn't let
me just check excuse me
excuse me there's not a camera on me
throw about nothing the main characters
of Seinfeld have been called a lot of
things selfish misanthropic
self-absorbed they all tend to feed off
of each other's nasty energy and that's
on display in this blooper George Jerry
and Elaine irritate George's Hospital
roommate so George tosses a cup over the
partition for at least eat rice
[Applause]
[Laughter]
the way the theme crumbles whether or
not a cookie can be made into a paste
and forced into the mouth of an
unconscious man as a debate you'll only
find on Seinfeld
but the insanity was too much for Jerry
and Julia
during this dank cookies no liquify
cookie Kramer vs Kramer Michael Richards
is just naturally funny the role of
Kramer often required him to be funny
with just a look a gesture or just by
playing existing a challenge he executed
a little too well sometimes cracking up
his castmates and ruining to take your
alright I'm sorry baby that's okay yeah
we did I don't know no part for you
TV Jerry Seinfeld was a stand-up
comedian just like the real Jerry
Seinfeld and like his real-life
counterpart TV Jerry sought out some
supplemental acting work on occasion but
the fictional Seinfeld was not nearly as
successful as the real deal cuz I can't
act I don't know what's all I'm that huh
bubbling over season fours the Bubble
Boy ranks among the silliest and most
memorable Seinfeld episodes in one theme
Jerry can't stop himself from jumping
the gun and explaining what a Bubble Boy
is a Bubble Boy yes he lives in a bubble
that's the Bubble Boy well I think Jerry
just explained that he's a whoops he's a
Bubble Boy a Bubble Boy he lives in a
bubble I'm sorry Michael
my brother he's a Bubble Boy a Bubble
Boy yes he lives in a bubble you schmuck
George wigs out after six seasons the
self-consciously bald George did
something about his problem and got
himself a toupee his newfound sense of
confidence draws new attention from the
opposite sex
George somehow manages to play it cool
and then actor Jason Alexander suffers a
George Costanza moment Garofalo goof AB
countless dates girlfriends dumped for
petty reasons and otherwise failed
relationships it looked like Jerry might
have finally found his match played by
Janeane Garofalo in the seventh season
episodes the invitations I tell you we
get tremendous you got a line I'm sorry
hey I'm kissing Jerry Seinfeld I get
nervous it's good luck to kiss ado on
perfect janenn think it's good luck to
kiss a Jew on Passover
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our YouTube channel
let's check out all this cool stuff we
know you love to
[Music]